it sounds like new york governor andrew
cuomo may want to call his lawyer
a former top trump doj official who
started looking into cuomo's nursing
home cover-up
says the governor should be worried
what governor cuomo's chief aide
secretary derosa admitted was that
the cuomo administration froze and
decided not to produce any information
there are federal criminal offenses for
obstruction of justice
for providing false data to the
government
and for concealing data from the
government and conspiring to
block a federal investigation
cuomo is facing increased bipartisan
backlash and calls to be investigated
but the white house is not giving a
clear answer on whether president biden
still stands by this praise of the
governor
your governor of new york's done one
hell of a job he i think he's
he's sort of the gold standard my
question was does
president biden still believe that
andrew cuomo is the gold standard
represents the gold standard
on leadership during this pandemic
just a yes or no well john the president
the pr
the president well it doesn't always
have to be a yes or no answer
john
it's so nice when democrats interview
other democrats all right dana so you're
looking at possible charges here
obstruction of justice
defrauding the government or conspiracy
and maybe even a separate
obstruction charge when he threatened to
destroy the career of the democrat
lawmaker who wouldn't lie
for him uh how bad is this getting well
i think like for example i think
jonathan carl from abc i'm
asking asking the right question which
is joe biden said one thing
in april of 2020 he needed andrew
cuomo's support
in order to get the nomination and then
ultimately hopefully
for the general election and got it and
now um
all the democrats are coming after cuomo
and even though
janzaki didn't give some sort of
full-throated defense of him basically
what she was saying is that
they're giving themselves some wiggle
room so if andrew cuomo i would imagine
feels a little lonely
today there's no port in a storm when
everybody's coming after you
he's been very powerful for a long time
he wants another
term as governor would be his fourth and
you even have somebody like bill de
blasio the mayor of new york city
arguably the worst mayor in the history
being able to shelter under this storm
because he's now taking pot shots at
cuomo while the rest of the city here is
like excuse me could you work on stuff
that we have to deal with here but
that's how big the scandal is and
to the point of that the lawyer made
obstruction of justice i think we
all agree is a serious crime and i hope
that they follow up on it
yes greg was very upset last week that
this actually
made bill de blasio yeah i'm still
excited all right greg
i'm still upset are you still upset by
this i know you know what it is i i
i realize that in a way i am like
batman and every now and then you have
to team up with the penguin
because the joker is that much worse and
de blasio is the joker uh
no the blasio is the penguin and uh
cuomo is the joker
and i'm either batman or robin or
batgirl
i haven't made up my mind yet it could
be both depends how i look in tights
oh robin's size yes i do all right one
one um you heard what we laid out the
possible charges
at the top um at least three um
do you think that they're gonna bring
charges it looks like the fbi and the uh
the uh i guess the department of justice
the uh
prosecutor in the in brooklyn is looking
into this
yeah i think it's going to be fully
investigated jesse the problem is it's
not clear
what crime was committed those crimes
that were listed by that
former uh i guess he was a d.a or a
former assistant i'm not sure
um but it's not clear that he broke any
of those laws what what is clear here
is he did cover up the number of deaths
at nursing homes
but he didn't cover up the number of
total deaths and
to me if you were a you know a
prosecutor you'd say
what was your intent in terms of what
you were doing
and he would say my intent was about
policy i thought i was pursuing
good intentions to for the state people
of my state
clearly he was wrong but that's not a
crime if that was a crime then you know
like
people saying oh i think this thing will
be over by easter would be a crime it's
not a crime
so right now we've got two governors in
this country
in big trouble one is cuomo because i
think he is going to be investigated on
this
but the other is greg abbott who's
trying to struggle with what's going on
in texas with people
who've been freezing people who don't
have drinking water
and right now if you look at the numbers
i think i'd rather be cuomo than abbott
because i think
people are going to hold a bitter pill
for us
a governor who didn't perform in the
middle of crisis
yeah i would strongly disagree greg did
i rudely cut you off when you had more
brilliant things to say i'm glad you did
so you're getting a little upset with me
i i'm glad you did because it got me to
listen to juan and watch him
once again do another lap on that old
canard about
it's not the cover-up of total deaths we
know that we've been talking about that
forever it's the cover-up of the
attribution okay
so now we're six months into this and
the tide is turning you're seeing
saturday night live jumping in because
they smell blood and
it's now democrat approved right where
were these brave wits
and columnists when it mattered when it
was happening
think about the five six or seven months
ago when we were talking about the
javits center and we were talking about
the hospital ship
that you know we saw every day on the
west side empty
um no one cared about that because you
couldn't say
you couldn't link that to the phrase
trump has blood on his hands
if you couldn't say trump has blood on
his hands after
that then you wouldn't mention it at all
so it was purely political
to let cuomo get away with this until
it's now no longer politically
feasible so now when you look back at
this period
history will not be kind to cuomo or his
brother or
everybody else who felt the only kind of
i spit
the only criticism could only be heaped
on trump
that's why i'm so angry it's okay i spit
earlier
uh dagin you heard juan say it wasn't
clear that cuomo
obstructed justice but his assistant
went out and said it she said we we held
back the numbers on purpose
yeah and that's obstruction yeah
admitting a cover-up
that's not a good look you know you know
what is a crime
there's an active federal investigation
yes the justice department and i'm not
sure but it's not obstruction can i
finish
one that's more obstruction than what
trump did but go ahead
the justice department asked new york
uh for detailed data in october
about um from hundreds of private
nursing homes they foot dragged
they did not provide that information
until
the very last days of the trump
administration jadis dean reported on
this that a justice department official
told her in december
that new york state had failed to
provide any data as of their october
request
so new york this is what the lawyer was
talking about
writing about the former doj worker
that the willful failure to provide
information may itself
constitute a criminal offense that is a
cover-up
that's the crime but i'll add this that
i think that just watching cuomo
even with the sound off you can see this
ogre
spiraling floundering sweating
desperation
saying things like no one has the right
to spread lies or misinformation that
causes pain to families
you listen to him and it's like he's
talking into a mirror
like travis bickle the psychopath